and also can I ask you towards what's up
with Trump bro what's up with them oh
wow
are you really voting for him I feel
like you are George does not like Trump
but he respects the game the game yeah
what do you mean it's a game tactics
know what he no no he's not gonna just
say something okay first of all he's
winning the game baby George is right no
no no just stop okay he's not winning
the game okay because what happened is
this okay Bush in 2008 left of left to
left us with a big mass to Wars you know
mean the economy is in the tube right
the stock the market crashed
then then Obama took over we used to be
10% unemployment rate now we're at 5% we
got out of Iraq right we got out of Iraq
right the war we killed Osama bin Laden
right and now it's like the Republicans
are like the people the Republicans are
like we hated Obama why we don't know
then we're gonna find our own guy right
so he's speaking a language to gather
these buffoons because let me tell you
this right now if you're anybody and you
like let's say I'm running for office
and the KKK you know me and David Duke
is supporting me and I don't refute him
or I don't you know I'm in and I go I
don't know much about the KKK so I'm not
gonna denounce you know he didn't do
that
Trumpton Trump didn't denounced the KKK
remember that and people still go went
if you vote for him after he does that
[ __ ] you're a [ __ ] racist it's all
crazy
you're not a racist if you say I don't
want Muslims in America that's racism
I mean Mexicans they're all you know I
mean most of them are like criminals and
whenever he said we're gonna build a
wall you know if you support a man who
says those things you're a full-blown
a racist in my opinion no you're right
but it doesn't mean so how is he winning
the game he is winning the game amongst
racists he's dummies but but you know
that just goes to show what America is
possibly made of right but George is
right he's still winning the game he's
winning the Republican game Conor
McGregor's but you don't realize that
yes with his contingency is that what is
this constituency is that the word yeah
is that the right word all right it
works with that group but those sound
bites work amongst you know I mean the
Republicans in his party whatever right
but when it becomes on 101 with Hillary
or Bernie those sound backs of sound
bites are gonna backfire into the mic
now [ __ ] it am I get under my voice
George has a pink ticket in the clock go
ahead I don't care let's talk preface
this by saying you were not even
reporter yeah yeah I'm not a trump
supporter I'm gonna vote libertarian
every time but that's that's a waste of
your vote but that's how I know that
it's a game I really have to respect
politics for the game it is okay Trump
as soon as he got them out like as soon
as he was getting the nomination he
started to soften everything every view
of him now has at least three women
supporting him okay what every time you
see Trump see you're still listen I know
exactly what you mean you're still
listening the media they're still trying
to crush Trump he's making sure he wins
with women now he's gonna have a megyn
kelly interview that's gonna come out
women are gonna love him okay you're
making assumptions you're making
assumptions I love them oh it's gonna be
hard for the coasts the coasts are still
gonna hate him but he's gonna soften
himself a lot to women and the rest of
America I think so I think New York LA
but he still gonna be how does he want
Hispanics over taco bowl he already
started with that yeah yeah that's when
you eat a taco ball and saying Trump
Plaza makes the best taco balls
I love Hispanics it's kind of sending
and we're not [ __ ] I know what
you're doing you're a trickster yes
anacs i follow George Lopez on Instagram
ain't fallin for it
whatever George says I listen so go
ahead it's gonna be an upward climb
impossible that's the start that's both
trolling so that everybody talks about
it and then shows that he loves
Hispanics he said like the most
politically correct term possible
Hispanics he says he wants to say
[ __ ] but he can't because he wants to
see [ __ ] but he can't right yeah and
what he said was number one that taco
salad thing is not a Hispanic Mexican
food right it's some sort of like you
know America like cross bred thing that
we created for white people to eat right
and it's like it's just condescending
the way he did it that's not the way
he'll never win them back you'll never
win them back he might not win him back
but he's going to try kind of soften the
edges a little bit more to where he
doesn't sound as sinister as he was
during the Republican race that would
because of those things that he has said
already the sound bites the recorded
right there tapes sometimes he says it
on tape right they can just use that in
ads against him no but then I also feel
like generating even negative airplay
about him still puts him in the
limelight in one way or another and in
that way he continues to win because
he's putting himself where the media is
putting him in the forefront of our
thoughts always so you you think and
this is gonna be the scariest question
I've ever asked you think George that he
could win the presidency he's got it if
he's up against Hillary so easy that's
some real [ __ ] you just said there man
um if you want to look at like read the
Scott Adams blog on it he has like the
he's been championing like what's gonna
happen he's been predicting what's gonna
happen since the beginning Scott Scott
Adams
Elbert we argue about this all every
time because I always say look like as
as the days go by to me it's a very
light like likely thing to happen it's a
huge possibility and he keeps saying
absolutely not it's gonna be a landslide
landslide landslide you know on the
Democratic side and I get I want to say
I can I don't think so you could be
right
and that's the first time I ever said
that in my life that George George can
be right and number two this is real
this is real and I'm gonna have to do
something we're gonna have to do
something we have to we have to get
involved and then the first and the
first thing we have to know this is what
we do
number one is we got to get burning out
of the race yeah yeah baby
by keeping Bernie in the race right he
brings up negative you know mean things
against Hillary right and it's like you
got to get him out of the race because
the longer he is in the more negatives
basically your spoon-feeding trump
things to say about yeah that's what I'm
saying yes if he didn't already have
everything at his disposal negative that
he would still out there Bernie's got to
get out I don't think so I love my burns
all right well then you're gonna have
Trump's gonna win and that's it
I think that Bernie has you know I know
that you know in terms of like the
delegate count it's a damn near
impossibility for Bernie to win at this
it's impossible but I will say that
probably it would be a more secure race
for us if Bernie won against Trump so
are you scared that Trump is going to be
president George what are you talking
about what is that I believe well why is
do you believe that did you vote for Ron
Paul Oh straight libertarian ticket
every year yeah but why you know they're
not gonna win because by voting for it
you like skew what people are like what
we're in a two-party system so the two
parties will always adopt beliefs that
are big enough
that if they can pull the people what do
libertarians believe tell me complete
freedom they believe you have the right
to do whatever you want as long as you
don't infringe on anybody else's rights
they're gonna end the drug war bringing
as many people as you like as many
immigrants as possible without like
completely ruining the economy like
complete freedom worldwide whatever yeah
don't you think that's dangerous don't
you think that like for instance gun
laws that we should have them yeah but
the it's the basis of any law that only
when it affects other people should you
not do it but it's none of those moral
laws like don't do it don't create a law
what about little fetuses there's little
baby fetuses who's gonna protect them
hey you forgot to greet me happy
Mother's Day Mother's Day you can't kill
the fetus we did all right B go B are up
you go B don't I'm not high-fiving that
because that's our daughter we didn't
have a choice all right George thank you
thank you George Arundel cause he just
completely stillborn politically
politically yeah I I don't talk about
politics ever because I don't know much
about it yeah obviously yeah how do you
know the right words to use but I do
have my opinions as in America and I
want to say those things Sam
[Music]